Es ist ein Abenteuer auf Leben und Tod.
Ich muss eine Nacht in der
Wildnis überstehen,
und das fast ohne Hilfsmittel. Für
mich eine große Herausforderung,
denn ich kenne mich nur in einem
Dschungel aus: meiner Heimatstadt Berlin.
Wenn ich hier den Weg nicht kenne,schau
ich einfach auf dem Smartphone nach.
Hab ich Hunger oder Durst,
bestell ich was.
Brauche ich Feuer – kein Problem!
Manchmal frag ich mich ja schon:
Was würd ich eigentlich machen,
wenn ich ohne all das
hier zurechtkommen müsste?
Am besten noch in der Wildnis.
Würde ich es schaffen, auch nur
eine einzige Nacht dort zu überleben?
Das will ich herausfinden.
Mit sieben weiteren Stadtmenschen
nehme ich in Thüringen an
einem Survival-Camp teil.
Überlebenstrainer Christoph
Weidner bringt uns die Tricks bei,
mit denen wir in der
Wildnis bestehen können.
Survival beginnt im Kopf.
Das ist mehr psycho
als wirklich Techniken
beherrschen und können.
Und Überlebenswillen
ist nicht antrainierbar.
Unsere erste Aufgabe:
Wir sollen in Zweiergruppen
einen vorab vereinbarten Treffpunkt finden.
Mein Teampartner Anthony
ist auch zum ersten Mal dabei.
Ich find, das macht einfach Spaß.
Man kommt auch irgendwie mal raus
und man ist auch ’n bisschen
befreiter so von dem ganzen Stress.
Im dichten Wald wird es schwierig.
Wie wir es heut Morgen gelernt haben,
versuchen wir, uns am Moosbewuchs
der Bäume zu orientieren.
Das wär auf jeden Fall
so ’ne Mooskante, oder?
Man muss natürlich dann mehrere Bäume
nehmen, wenn man sich jetzt so umguckt.
Das Moos soll auf nordwestlicher Seite
wachsen. Aber ohne Moos nix los.
Wir befragen sicherheitshalber
den Kompass.
Aber auch das ist ohne
Übung gar nicht so einfach.
Das … die Navigationsübungen
heute Morgen waren ja ganz schön und gut.
Aber wenn man dann wirklich dabei
ist und den Kompass in der Hand hat
und das versucht, herauszufinden,
wo man langgehen muss …
Ich bin jetzt total lost, ehrlich gesagt.
Immerhin finden wir den Treffpunkt,
ohne uns groß zu verlaufen.
Hier werden wir unser
Nachtlager aufschlagen
und testen schon mal
den Härtegrad des Waldbodens.
Aus Ästen bauen wir
uns einen Unterschlupf.
Der erste Aha-Effekt:
Mit den elastischen Kiefernwurzeln
lassen sich die Äste gut verknoten.
Christoph Weidner zeigt uns,
wie wir unser Obdach
stabil und wasserdicht bauen können.
Den First für unsere Konstruktion
richten wir so aus,
dass die Öffnung zur
windstillen Richtung weist.
Dünne Zweige und Unmengen
von Laub halten Wasser ab
und die Wärme im Innenbereich.
Darum soll der Schlafraum auch
möglichst klein und kuschelig sein.
Aber, man ist schon echt …
Ach, das geht voll.
Ja.
Danach treibt uns der
Hunger wieder weiter.
Du kannst diese … diese frisch
austreibenden Blätter von Laubbäumen
kannst du im Frühjahr essen.
Aber gut schmecken tun die nicht.
Neben Haselnussknospen und Hagebutten
ernte ich auch noch Sauerklee.
Das ist echt ganz lecker!
Aber satt wird man davon irgendwie nicht.
Doch Wasser ist ja eh viel wichtiger.
An feuchten Talsenken wie hier
sollte man sich auf die Suche
nach Wasserquellen machen.
Wir haben eine gefunden – zugegeben
mit Hilfestellung.
Für mich eine schöne Erkenntnis:
Das Wasser sprudelt hier in
Trinkqualität einfach so heraus.
Das schmeckt wie aus ’m Supermarkt.
Ebenso wichtig: Feuer machen!
Dafür brauche ich einen kleinen
Stapel Zweige und als Zunder:
Birkenrinde, denn die ist teerhaltig.
Ich schabe etwas von
der äußeren Haut ab,
komme aber nicht
ohne Spezialausrüstung weiter:
Mit Feuerstahl kann ich durch Reibung
extrem heiße Funken erzeugen.
Ja!
Ich habe es geschafft, wenn auch
nach vielen erfolglosen Versuchen.
Aber endlich können wir die Würstchen
grillen, die unser Trainer aus Mitleid
über die magere
Sammelausbeute spendiert hat.
Keiner soll mit schlechten
Erinnerungen gehen.
Also das hoffe ich eigentlich immer am
meisten. Also dass wirklich so diese …
das Feuer entfacht wird für
Draußen-Sein wieder.
Ich hab jetzt auch keine andere
Wahl, als draußen zu sein.
Nun wartet die letzte Herausforderung:
übernachten im dunklen Wald.
Gute Nacht!
Nacht.
Gute Nacht.
Acht Uhr morgens: Ich werde von
Vogelgezwitscher geweckt.
Guten Morgen!
Ganz bequem war die
Nacht zwar nicht,
aber trotz Temperaturen im einstelligen
Bereich hab ich nicht gefroren.
Also, es war ’ne tolle Erfahrung.
Aber jetzt bin ich echt ganz schön kaputt.
Ich war überrascht,
wie schnell es funktioniert,
sich ’nen Unterschlupf zu bauen,
und wie schwer es ist,
Feuer zu machen.
Aber jetzt freue ich mich vor
allem auf ’ne warme Dusche
und ’n leckeres, leckeres warmes Essen.
Also schnell weg hier. Aber was will
ich mehr: Ich habe überlebt.
Und komme bestimmt bald mal
wieder – zurück in die Natur.